um and today i kind of wanted to go over
a really interesting game i didn't know
what to do or what player to select i
don't i didn't want to talk about
uh how
i became a wgm i wanted to talk about
something else so um i
was browsing through books and i decided
to talk about kasparov
and
this is a really exciting game it's not
necessarily the game that made him a
grandmaster
but it's a game from the year that he
became a grand master in 1980
and
it's just a really cool game overall i
really like the the structure and the
style of the game so
we'll just
go ahead and see i guess
he was white pieces
he was white pieces so
um in his
book uh he kind of mentioned that uh
1980 was kind of like his best year
because he got i believe like four gold
medals and a couple of championship wins
and he became a grand master and he
finished his studies
he does in one year what i can't do in
my whole lifetime
so
my coach told me that he told him that
he didn't like speed chess it was
garbage
he said i'm
teach you speed test is gonna be the
thing well you know
if it was here today
yeah yeah yeah yeah all right hi
michigan eagle hi cooper how's it going
all right so i'm just going to go ahead
and get started
uh it was d4 knight f6 c4 g6 knight c3
v5 do you know the
do you know
no this is uh we started off with d4 uh
and this is the group oh yeah yeah
i'm sorry
like kings
yeah greenfield is what with d5
controlling the center instead of bishop
g7
which is the kings
so
yeah
he even played this with black
later on
in his life
um but in the in this time his white
pieces and i think i forgot to mention
he's playing against joseph priti
in the european
championship in
ba cool
1980 yeah
so c takes
d5 knight takes e5 e4
knight c3
this is all normal so far bishop to g7
knight to f3
and
um
i believe he mentioned that at the time
probably the most common line it was
bishop to c4 there are a lot of games in
the carp of kasparov match um in this
variation in the groomfield like a lot
and i actually studied some of them for
some
um because i played this as black
so
yeah
but knight to f3 is a move that was
played
in the game and then uh black pieces
made a very curious move he went pawn to
b6 and this is kind of unusual
because
um first of all the main move is pawn to
c5
there's bishop right you kind of want to
activate it but he might be going b6 to
go knight h5 and then c flat but that's
floor but yeah it is solar i mean you
don't you don't have to play b6 to get
c5 in
so you can just do it right away and the
whole point of this opening for those
who don't know is that
um
black is giving up the center
essentially because you can see that
white controls most of it
but the whole point is that with the
bishop and opponent c5 and the rest of
the remaining pieces developing you're
gonna put out put uh trouble in that
center that you gave to white so
yeah pretty much
so b6 was a little slow um
they kind of agreed on this it was a
very peculiar decision if you don't want
to play c5 you can also castle so that's
another thing
um but b6 was played in like i said
not very common yeah this is a green
film you gotta give him a little temp
time you know
so
bishop to b5 check
and this was a very interesting check in
the game pawn to c6 was played and then
bishop to c4 and it almost feels like
yeah i mean the thing is that white
doesn't actually mind moving the bishop
twice because the bishop is more optimal
on c4 and at the same time the pawn is
on c6 the pawn wants to be on c5 but
it's on c6 right now
and then the knight also can get out to
the natural square so it's kind of
trying to
disrupt the black pawn structure a
little bit
if uh
black had played bishop to d7
which
is a possibility
you can just go back and then after pawn
to c5 bishop to f4 this is just kind of
normal i guess you can even castle
instead
um but essentially the bishop is a
little awkward here on d7 you already
played b6 so it would be nice if the
bishop was on b7
yeah
but yeah it's a little awkward here on
this side nothing crazy or anything but
just that
i kind of succeeded at messing up the
the setup that that black wanted yeah
so this check was very interesting even
in games from like um uh
bobby fischer against
uh
spassky
like there are some fun bishop g5s
creating weaknesses
however c6 was played bishop c4 as i was
saying
and castle castle all natural and bishop
to a6
now after bishop to a6 obviously it's
offering an exchange and
in general senses this would be
beneficial for black because they have
less space in the position
but at the same time
some weaknesses could be left behind
after this and one problem is that after
bishop takes a6 knight takes a6
where would you like to go with the
queen
i'd probably like to go d3
d3 yeah and then it's attacking this
night right here
in the game he in the game he went queen
eight four so it's kind of similar right
it's attacking here
he's doing a
the problem with the exchange is that it
made the piece worse right so we know
that usually we want to make trades that
improve uh the location of our pieces
yeah you're right
uh
queen to c8 and the
the the problem is that you'll see that
throughout the rest of the game there's
not an a6 was a huge problem yeah it was
it was out of place and
um
in this positions it's kind of important
for
black to try and put pressure on the
center otherwise white can consolidate
and start pushing the pawns so we'll see
a little bit of that
um coming up
high fives how are you
okay so queen to c8 was played um
and now bishop to g5 so every move that
white is making right like queen to a
four attack here and here now the bishop
yeah if you can develop pieces and
attack um
and attack it
and attack the the opponent's pieces at
the same time
it's always beneficial right it almost
feels like you're on the right track
because
you're developing and also attacking so
just kind of like winning tempos putting
your pieces in better squares
it's all good right right
queen to be seven
defending the pawn
kind of overloading though
that is true and that's why he played
rook to e1
and there is one idea after rook two e1
so let's say that
black does a silly move like
pawn to h6 like they completely ignore
what's going on in the position
yeah bishop takes e7
queen takes queen takes and the whole
point of this last move rook to e1 is
that now they cannot
and that is that was a whole point of
root 21 just to make sure that um e4 is
protected
it's a center pawn you don't really want
to lose it you don't want to trade it
off necessarily right so just protect it
and now you do have the threat for
upcoming moves so it's going to be a
little difficult for
for black to ignore right right
pawn to e6
and i believe that they were discussing
like whether to play pawn to e6 or rook
to e8 yeah um
both of them are really just non-harmful
moves to the to the white position
uh pawn to e6 it could prevent some d5
ideas i would say that essentially
they're like about the same
in general though in this position
they're fine but in general um if you
have the option
to
defend
by moving upon or moving another piece
to defend that pawn usually you want to
move the
because you're piece right
yeah you develop but also the thing is
that the pawns don't go back right so
you don't want to like accidentally move
a pawn forward and then leave a witness
behind
yeah
this was actually a trick question in um
in the in like a lecture that i was in
uh many years ago with the grand master
and the problem is that
like i was maybe 11 so i could kind of
12 i could kind of understand like what
he was referring to but there were like
seven year olds in the in the lecture
and they were like what does that even
mean
so that was a little funny yeah see the
only thing about when he moved upon he
still could put the bishop attacking the
rook
he has to take a move and move the rook
over because he takes with the queen
still dropped tonight you see what i'm
saying
yeah yeah
and i don't know what would that be put
the bishop in a better position or what
you know what i'm saying might get to d6
and then the pawn comes to e5 and that's
pretty well
yeah we're gonna see how this diagonal
actually plays some
some importance later
it says that bishop keeps that rook
from coming to d.a yeah that is very
important actually
so
pawn to e6 was played
and rook to b1 this is actually a very
interesting move uh rook to b1
it has this one idea that uh
that we're going to see in the next move
um
yeah but essentially one key thing often
times in the groomfeld
when you're playing as wide just to be
sure you don't really want the rook in
the diagonal of the bishop so just for
safety since the point is to move the
center pawns right since the goal is to
move this pawns forward
get the rook out of the way so there is
nothing going on hidden threats
right yeah that next c3 would fart both
looks you know the bishop get down
sometimes it's okay some sometimes if
you want you can even give up the rook
and that's fine because this bishop is
really strong and it protects a lot of
the king but in this scenario that's not
really necessary black already has the
problems of the knight in the corner and
they have less space so there is no need
to
like give them some sort of counter
chance with material because yeah e5
looks pretty
we could play five or we can also try to
play for c4 and d5
so those are some ideas but before that
we need to get the rook out of the way
so this is more of like um this is kind
of like a prophylactic galactic move
yeah yeah that's a good one also his
queen is sick behind it you know what
i'm saying yeah that might throw some
tactics up there and this is kasparov
who we're talking about so
yeah yeah
um
all right
so
pawn to c5 was played
and it's kind of trying to challenge
the
um it's kind of trying to to challenge
the center a little bit right
we don't want to take here because then
the knight would get a really nice
square yeah really nice
and he's hitting those two at c3 pond
remember
yeah
uh caspar was playing joseph privy i
think i'm saying his name right
i think it was the european team's
championship
in 1980 and it was like a team event
right and obviously the soviet union
um and
uh i believe he scored five and a half
out of six so it was like a really good
um really good tournament really great
performance i know it's a slow idea but
i almost like moving the queen to see
ford and start that eight partner prayer
because his queen is backed up
in general this could be an idea just to
put pressure on the pawns so it makes
sense
okay but let's see what happened because
i think you might be
in the right track so
d5 was played
and that was another one of the of the
strong points of rook b1 right as
mentioned
before
the queen where the queen can't leave
the knight actually so it's still
a stronger threat than it looks like
isn't it yeah so this is not possible
because this is hanging in the knife
protects b5 so it's all good
um
and
uh technically you could play this if
you want to but this is not as good
this is not as good as um
just taking the the
pawn right away because you do open up
the e file so now
oh oops i moved something
now there are ideas of rook to each
other
he doesn't infiltrate his back that
little path pawn is getting strong
yeah so this can be a problem
so that is why
they didn't take but they did play
bishop take c3
and after bishop takes c3 it simply rook
d1
so um
just as a as a general thing of some
gumfeld structures sometimes it's okay
to give up the opponent's c3 i mean it
it's not the best thing in the world
right if you don't have to don't do it
right uh but if you do it's gonna
and
give
you
an
a little comp for it you know uh you
in this case you don't get an open file
but you do get compensation because of
the strong pawn here on d5 and in this
specific scenario
the bishop on c3 right now it's a little
bit loose the knight is on a6 which
might need to regroup in the future the
bishop controls a really strong diagonal
and the pawn also has ideas of promoting
so
in this moment there are a lot of things
that black needs to take care of and
they might not be able to take care of
all of those things at the same time
so white will have enough compensation
in the sense that their idea is very
clear just pushing the pawn forward and
at the same time
it's hard to keep everything under
control as black so
for example um
the pawn on c5 is an extra pawn the
black has but you can't really compare
it to the strength of the pawn on d5
simply because
you know it just has a straight way
ahead to keep going to promotion
yeah
i think wow
hitting the bishop would force him to do
something and affect the pond
and then moved away for the a
two pond to come up i'm just thinking
i'm not a grandmaster
well
you're not a grandmaster so that's why
you're in how to become around us
um
here in this scenario though we do have
the pawn on d5 which like i said earlier
it's very strong so we don't really need
to play a4a5 right now just because we
have one clear plan and we can go ahead
with that quickly so
rook to d1
e takes d5 e takes d5
now it makes more sense the rook is not
on the e file so he can't get to e7
um
so bishop to g7 simply going back makes
sense don't leave pieces unprotected so
bishop back
pawn to d6 you can kind of tell that
it's beginning to get serious with the
d-pawn it's very close to
um
yeah i mean if it gets to the e7 and all
of a sudden you have to be very
bishop
and brooks can't come and oppose it
and the queen can't oppose it yeah the
queen is also stuck defending this this
knight right here and the knight doesn't
have great squares as we can see
so there are just a lot of things going
on right now
and that is why black decided to play
pawn to f6
and pawn to f6 you know it makes sense
because it is blocking the bishop from
controlling
square yeah from controlling the
queening square so
i feel like this is a good moment to
uh stop for a little bit let me take
away this arrow
to stop for a little bit and try and see
what's the right way to continue you
don't have to you don't have to give me
like a specific move in particular it
would be nice if you calculate because
um you know this is like aspirin of game
like you had it set up from the start
um
but uh yeah this is a good moment to try
and think about what is actually going
on in the position and anyone present or
in chat feel free to just
um
say what you think
is interesting about the position
and something that you think might be
able to
help you find the correct move or if you
have a
variation you know
you can say it as well just don't tell
me like
one move and that's it
um
but yeah i guess anything works anyway
so yeah just take like a moment to try
and see what's going on here
based on
what i mentioned before which i guess
are some hints but also what you realize
on your own
or you can have like a couple of
candidate moves and then
um try to come up with a variation so we
have
one line
suggested with quincy for king h8 and
bishop f4 we are grouping the bishop
that's one thing
um or we should be three it seems okay
i'm gonna give it a few minutes because
this is like a very interesting position
ah but bishop e3 does not threaten
bishop take c5
the pawn cannot take it but the with the
nikon so that's the thing
to be careful about
the bomb could be a weakness in the
future but right now the the knight is
still protecting it yeah
talia just wants a five minute break now
i know we'll get some moves i'm giving
you guys a chance
uh queen f7 is not an idea that
black house in the future because it's
gonna keep the night unprotected
but i mean if the night moves then yeah
the queen is free to do whatever they
swap queen that are free tonight a
little bit
oh you mean after
okay so they were saying bishop
he could pull the green up but if he
does and they swapped
yeah white doesn't actually want to make
that many trades here because remember
there are pawn downs so
they want to use the initiative that
they have from the pawn and also f6 if
you think about it never play f6 right
the game might be weak
so
um blocked his bishop which was the
strongest piece in here yeah
yeah but he had to do it because some
threats were getting pretty strong now
mm-hmm
yeah yeah
[Music]
rookie one to player k7 that's an
interesting idea okay one
[Music]
c4 would be strong you know because you
can infiltrate the seventh run
um
let's say
takes
i'm guessing
rookie seven
i'll play queen d5
i think this works
and if
yeah and if here here i think i have
this
queen takes here
and here
also this
so i think the fact that the queen
manages to get away is a good thing for
for black
yeah
he can double them looks and didn't
break the queen to the background that's
what i'm looking at but i feel like you
know the move rookie one is kind of
close
you the focus of this position and the
idea of the move that was played is the
fact that
black's pieces as mentioned before are
very stuck right right so
he probably did something a little more
subtle like queen to eat i mean
bishop e3 or something
okay
maybe i'll show what i'll i'll give like
a minute or two
if anyone wants to give a last
suggestion and then i might show the
move that i mean
someone is blurring their current home
indicating they would like to suggest a
move i think it's more of like a sign of
a sound of like no this is not the move
but whatever
i mean to be fair it's a very direct
threat right upon two of six
and at the same time
you know
this weekend that i don't know the
knight on 86 still kind of
far away i would say it's a hard move to
guess just by looking at the position
this one that was playing
but once you once you start thinking
about it it's kind of like oh yeah that
makes
that makes sense
okay i think i'm just gonna go ahead and
show the move
and then
you guys can tell me if you
ever consider that
or not
um
95 what's the point of 95
i thought about that
because in the
well it puts the pressure on left seven
when if you get that check in now you
got to be very careful
oh well if it takes that way i guess
this is the plum right yeah that's the
point
everything you take the night i thought
he'd take the mission
uh if he takes the bishop i think taking
the bishop uh
this can get very interesting but i
think taking the bishop
let's say uh i don't know what you want
to do now though
um
well actually check i can just move away
because if knight f7 is covered twice
so
well okay then the pond pushes you so
you don't oh but be careful because
you're running out of pieces
it's a little bit it's a little bit it's
kind of close to that idea
but you see
as a final hint as a final hint
um
95 oops sorry 95 takes queen here king
here
what you're saying
you're saying knight g6
and then rook lift ideas
i have rook of rook f4
yeah i think i have rook four
or bishop h6 um but yeah so the problem
with with this position right is that
you don't have time to play knight to f7
so
that's going to be a little bit of a
hint
it's going to be a little bit of a hint
and the correct move here or at least
you know the most interesting one is uh
actually pawn to d7
oh you just stacked the bishop and then
the nightclub
yeah yeah
the main point is that it kind of cuts
the connection like if you think about
it you divide the board
like uh in the d file you kind of just
completely separate the two sides right
because the queen cannot go anywhere
near um i mean it can go here only right
like holding off the
the file completely
and it has to be stuck here defending
the night
and
um at the same time
you know the pawn is just one step
closer to promotion and as mentioned
f7
you know it's really hard to cover f7
and the king now
also this bishop
uh if the pawn takes of course uh this
bishop has a beautiful long diagonal but
it doesn't attack anything
it's like me sometimes useless but it
doesn't attack anything but
okay
but this diagonal is the one that we
care about it would be nice it would be
nice if black had a light square bishop
but they don't right
so
yeah
um so d7 let's just go over
some of the
he got time to double the rooks you know
push the pile on through
because he he's got a good position he
just got a
yeah now that's when the when the
fireworks kind of begin to
to shine
so
let's say that what happened in the game
was pawn takes like uh takes here but
let's say that you know
they don't try to do that i believe that
night before was the move that carpool
suggested after the game remember this
is a team tournament so like they have
it they have everyone uh almost i guess
in europe i guess uh
and they probably analyzed this game i
believe that kasparov actually
up
to this time he counted this as like his
best game
uh later he had like
even more brilliant games but yeah up to
this time
so if knight to e4
uh
there are some interesting stuff so
queen to b3 makes sense giving a check
king goes to the side
and bishop to f4 simply retreating from
coming to that
yeah
and this is just a lot of a vintage
like positional advantage uh for white
because the queen actually is gonna do
some really fun rear grouping it's gonna
go to b3 and e6
and controlling some key squares around
the pawn and also the king
meanwhile the queen on b7 is not able to
do the same type of rear grouping the
knight is on b4 but it doesn't control
that much and essentially white's idea
is going to be rook d6 rookie one
doubling up also kind of controlling the
screen c6 in case the knight wants to go
back
so yeah
no it's not a carpet game it's a caspar
of game
karpov suggested knight to b4 as like
you know analyzing after the game but
this is a kasparov game so keen h1 is
not happening
king h1 is not happening
um
however really quickly there are some
kind of 95 ideas just with the fact that
you know pawn takes here and then the id
the threat of 97 knight f7 is a little
more real but after f takes e5 d8 takes
takes takes
um it's not so clear
it's it's not so clear like it's still
better
but somehow it's just easier to go for
the other line than for this one
so
yeah
because there are a lot of puns it's two
pawns for the
for the exchange so yeah
oh my god it's also his birthday today i
forgot it's caspara's birthday
maybe that's why
no i can't i mean i saw it i saw it i
saw it online but i forgot about it and
then i was preparing the lecture i
wasn't planned i guess i also i'm also
very forgetful at times so
yeah
he's not watching this but happy
birthday
okay um but anyways so knight to b4
wasn't played
and you know sometimes you just gotta
take and pray that they don't find the
good moves right
so
f6 e5 was played
queen to c4 makes sense no rook f7
whoops no rook f7 punk remotes
um so k2h8 and knight takes g5 we don't
go the e5 routes because of the bishop
but we can take on g5
and we're threatening knight to f7 and
some other move actually so for example
if
if i just make like a
random move let's say knight to b4
what is one
like what is what is uh like a winning
sequence here with the smug
it if uh
seven and the king got a move now i
think he might get the smothered mate if
you don't yeah
yeah he takes it
there's this but he can take on f7
yeah he has to take on he has a dick on
f7 there's also just uh just to change
the move order there's also just d8
and um
yeah
that is also winning
but okay so there are just a lot of
threads in this position
um i don't know if there are any lines
that i'm not covering
uh
this is fine so yeah
there are just a lot of threads here so
bishop to f6 was played
kind of gives a square to the king right
here on g7
and also kind of controls
the promotion stuff right right but then
at night
yeah yeah
so
if going to f7 right now there is just
king g7 and
there is not much really right yeah i
think you can just
yeah i don't know if you can take i
guess you can take
yeah
i guess you can take
something like this
and all of a sudden it's white who's in
trouble
um
yeah
so the night going the f7 route kind of
doesn't
fulfill any purpose right now
so knight to e6
knight to c7
um
knight to c7 so essentially what black
is trying to do they're trying to give
back some of the material
right to try and defend and make things
a little bit easier also as mentioned
the knight kind of was doing nothing on
e6 so at least now on c7 it's a little
bit
more in the game right and if you manage
to trade off the knight on c7 for the
knight on e6 it's a huge improvement for
black because the knight was always bad
and the night you know the the white
knight was always like jumping around
and threatening the king so it would be
of an official trade right
um
yeah
so after knight to c7
knight takes f8 rook takes f8
and
let's see
i mean you can't threaten the bishop you
can play rook to d6 it's kind of a move
that has been around
a little bit like you know we mentioned
before some lines with rook to e6 and
the queen coming to e6
so that is one idea uh
okay so actually someone wanted to play
queen to f4 that's kind of interesting
considering
what
what happened later but i don't want to
foreshadow anything so
so this is the threat ryder takes up six
rook takes of six and the age
um
and of course that is winning
also rook on d6 if you think about it
just cuts the knight further the knight
doesn't really do that much in c7 it's
so close to controlling the eight but
it's so far away at the same time
um
i if i'm not mistaken i believe kasparov
said that queen takes c5 was his
original idea
you know because after it takes takes
right and you know
yeah there's just ideas of this but
there's one interesting move after queen
takes e5 that can make that a little bit
you know crazy
yeah there's one there's one curious
move after queen takes e5
and then all of a sudden it's not clear
all of a sudden it's not clear
yeah it might be a little preoccupied at
the moment to solve puzzles so
it's just moves
like here
yeah it would hit the rook and
that would hit his the other guy's queen
and also
protect the queen and squat hit the rook
and
guard the coin and square
well the thing about this move is that i
can move my queen and attack the knight
at the same time
right so i think i can go
here let's say
and you have to defend the night because
the night defense will work
it just becomes a little bit hard to do
that
uh it's just one one really funny move
in this position
uh it's not such an important line it's
just one one funny idea so after
cleantech c5 instead of taking right
away and allowing the rook to get here
um for free you can just take
and after quintex g2 can take six at
least you got the pawn on g2 and it
might look like it's close to doing
something but after rook 2
2 b7 bishop to d8 rook takes king g7 if
you start thinking about it it's not so
clear how to
how to proceed right
like
it's it's still better for white but
there is no need to
get into this complications when you
have a much clearer way too
he does have that little passer
he did say that this was his original
idea queen takes e5 but then he saw rook
to d6 so he went for it
rook to d6 bishop to e7
and the question here is how do we
proceed we have two main ideas
right so we have the point promotion and
we also have the weak king because if
you think about it like the king is very
open right right
with the chick with f uh c3
uh well i guess it only has one move
can go there
and these checks are nice but there is
one idea
there's one idea that is just kind of
like very
i guess um
not just the goodyear and maybe just the
best uh chess player ever
um
but
as i as mentioned you have two ideas so
you can either
continue with both of them you can let
one take over if you think that you have
enough
tactical resources i guess to do so
um so
in this position right here there's just
kind of a very beautiful sequence of
moves
um you can think about it for a moment
if you want
um
yeah but there's uh
there's just a really nice sequence
and the whole point of it is just to
improve where the pieces are located
so that an attack can work better
so that other rook might need to get in
the battle i gotta see where they're
gonna put it
but we also only have three pieces left
so we have to be careful with what type
of sacrifices we do right because
if you if you you know
play like tao and you start sacrificing
pieces you might not have enough to
check on it later that's true so
yeah
you say uh
like rook takes sacrifice on the pawn
the problem with this is that queen
move the other h4 like from b to d you
know so when you take you still got
another rook there
i was talking about someone here in the
in the comment section
um yeah but i guess with the rook here
the the same problem still stands that
there might be bishop takes
uh yeah there might be bishop takes and
after rope takes
do i have any sneaky move or do i have
to defend
um
i think
i think
[Music]
maybe i have to play queen
queen b8
after that
and i don't think you have enough to win
it's past midnight in europe and you had
drinks
that's a life
okay um
yeah so it would be nice if you could it
would be nice if you know if you could
kind of similar to what someone
mentioned here
to play queen to f4 but it would be nice
if this rook was more active maybe in a
more active um
rank right
so that's kind of the it's like a
remaneuvering
idea
after bishop b7
i can't beat you with my eyes closed and
nobody telling me the moves
um
maybe
uh rook d3
i think rook d3 is possible
uh
let's see root d3
rook t3
i'm trying to find a way to activate
pieces but it's a little hard
now that i think about it
maybe rook d3 i don't know if you are
giving me enough time to do something
with my queen but the question is where
maybe i can play queen to c6
and if this now this works
because the queen is protecting it so
yeah
um
yeah
so
do you remember like like uh some time
ago when i
asked for a move and it was pawn to d7
and that was like the right answer
you remember so in this case
the right move is
d8 just keep throwing the pawn forward
and the whole idea it's very beautiful
because you're giving away probably the
the one thing that you have played for
up until now
but obviously cause power to understand
how to shift
the type of advantage that you have and
in this case it's no longer obviously
he's no longer
using the advantage of the past pawn
as like the main thing but he's going to
use it to
allow his pieces to have more space and
the rook to get to the seventh rank and
he's gonna focus on the king now
so that's kind of the point
um
that is kind of the point
so after d8
bishop takes queen c3 obviously you
can't cover with the bishop
it just takes
king uh to g8 and now you
you could get this position but with the
pawn on d7 and the difference is that
now you can play rook to d7
yeah right
and that's pretty rude yeah rook f7 rook
takes
there are just so many things going on
and not only that but also i know it's
less important but also like there is a
pin going on on this side
right right
that was just a very nice idea very nice
idea so bishop to f6 only move queen c
4 king 2 h8 and queen 2 f4 and you see
how like the pieces regrouped and we
kind of talked a little bit about sorry
not that about the queen going to 2f4
and kind of making a pin here
but this is just a much stronger version
because
there is an attack here on c7 right and
it's not so easy to know how to cover
the best move in the position would have
been bishop to
g7 just kind of forgetting about this
knight completely
and after bishop to g7
queen takes c7 takes takes and you do
get into this sun game
and it ki it's kind of the thing that
gives the most hope to black
but white is still much better after
bishop d4 obviously very important is
rook to f1 not allowing rook takes
because it gets counter play on the king
and also taking the a pawn maybe
um and
after something like a6 simply rook c6
and to defend upon rook f6 but after
takes takes rookie
the rook is getting to
e6
and i would say it's like plus one plus
two
so that would have been the best
continuation
oh did i not talk about what happens if
rook d8 okay
one second
it's not so clear
so
technically that would have been the
best for
you could lose them with both colors i
feel that way about a lot of positions
um
yeah if he takes with the rook
right that was the question so if he
takes with the rook
what happens there's kind of a big
problem going on
and it's really hard to take care of it
if you
think about it
well when that queen can come down to
the five block and the queen can make it
to
f7
then it's almost one move to mate
kind of
the
look the
the bishops on the back row and so how
is he going to defeat that square
yeah it's not so easy to defend
everything that's kind of being thrown
out right now right you can't play rook
d7 because of rook takes um
yeah
so
the the problem is that the pieces are
gonna kind of be stuck on the other side
right so after something like rook d8
bishop d8
um how do you
continue
there's oh sorry there's this and
there's oops and there's this move
if you look it's the bishop but he can
still move and control the squad
i think both of them work
uh
i don't know which one is exactly more
direct
i would say yeah i would say just both
of them win by bias i kind of want to
play rook here first just so that i
control the d file
but i think queen 2f7 also works because
you're playing queen to f8
and
white i mean black needs to do something
about it right and the only thing that i
can kind of see right now to not lose
material right away or get checkmated
it's going to d5 but after queen to d5 i
mean we could play maybe queen to f8 but
we also have this so
i mean
kind of
winning anyways
so yeah
i like to think rook d8 might be a
little better just so that this is not
possible
um
but yeah i think both of them should
work like a bishop here obviously this
so yeah
it just kind of takes away a defender of
the king so
yeah the bishop takes queen c3 king g8
rook d7 and then we have this really
nice idea you know continuing with the
checks until queen f4 and as i mentioned
the attack was here so as i said bishop
to g7 maybe was the best continuation
and i believe that uh privy later was
you know kind of regretting that he
didn't play this but if i'm not mistaken
they had about a minute in the clock at
the time so
it's really hard to play you might think
that bishop g7 is kind of natural but he
actually ended up playing
uh queen to a6
what's what's like a move that finishes
off the game here
there are a lot of good moves
as you can probably imagine
but there's one move that just kind of
cuts the game entirely
yeah queen h6
and i mean this knight is hanging but we
don't really care about it
queen h6 and there is no way to stop
all of the mates that are
coming
so yeah queen 86 was kind of like a
final blunder it just kind of doesn't
you know doesn't even give a chance um
it's made in four if i'm not mistaken
like you gotta start sucking the queen
and stuff
um
but
yeah that was kind of the end to to this
game
yeah yeah queen h6 and resigns yeah
black ended up resigning in this
position
obviously as mentioned the knight was
hanging but
you know if you have mate right away
just
yeah don't allow the queen to get in and
maybe spook you a little bit
um yeah so this was just the end to the
game and i i thought that overall it was
a very beautiful game it almost seems
like
white pieces was
uh i just noticed he also hit the rook
too
and if um
it almost felt like white was the one
who led the game all throughout right
so
yeah even from the beginning
it's kind of very like kasparov style
where even if he has to give up a little
bit of material remember the opponent's
c3
with the move
and they could take here on c3 they just
kind of
uh
they open up the position
it opens up the position even if it
gives up a pawn but it is white who has
the initiative and who will be taking
you know the leading role
um and then we later just saw how easily
it became you know to infiltrate into
the position
and it's really hard uh when you're on
the defending side because you have to
be extremely precise sometimes when
you're attacking you have the liberty of
you know a little emphasize yeah
but you just lose your initiative
but if you're defending you do have to
be extremely accurate then you know as
you can see
uh from this game black tried to defend
for a long time but it was really hard
and white kept finding the
best moves
squeeze you know yeah time pressure
always you know
always uh makes things harder
so yeah that was kind of the
the whole game as mentioned kasparov
believed this was suspect's best game to
to that
to that time and i believe he analyzed
it that night with yusupov and
you know
usable was like
wow it's just beautiful it's hard to
play like you
and then he went on to praise him and
all that so
yeah but it was just a very nice game
and it almost felt like it just kind of
led that way black didn't do any huge
blunder or mistake right
yeah
just you know like you said that b6 that
wasn't really hit the ground field like
he was about to get behind in tempo
because he should have gone c5 instead
of b6
that got kind of slow i believe you know
some people said that b6 was the reason
why
black lost but i mean obviously it's
just the opening right but they kind of
mean that it was kind of the start of
the problem that b6 because that kind of
caused the pieces to be in awkward
squares and as we know that went on for
the rest of the game especially the
night on a6 and then you know from that
what kind of got the ideas to play with
the initiative and such so yeah
well i hope you guys like this lecture
and i hope the people watching also like
the lecture
and
um
yeah feel free to
i don't know if there are any more
lectures today feel free to watch if
there are any and
on youtube and twitch perfect
amazing so go watch that uh chess and
psychology i think
and um
yeah and check out the
american cup next week i'm very excited
about it so
top players in the us plus my greek
friend
it's just how it is um
but uh
yeah um go check out the tournament it's
going to be extremely strong
and
yeah i guess that's gonna be all for
today i'm just gonna go ahead and end
the stream
um so yeah thank you so much everyone
for watching bye bye